[音楽]
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
parse 2
[拍手]
ブーバーありがとうござい
1んだ
ありがとうございます次5
良い子から南まで待ってよねだけん
僕が誕生日はちょっと特殊で鍛造日の日にバレンタイン
るっていうその何女の海でチョコあげたいややにチョコをあげたりやれねーそういう日
なんですよ俺的には俺の誕生日を祝ってほしいのに何かそういうバレンタインデーの
せいでな頃の誕生日[ __ ]不味い違ってなんかその男女比のなんかそういうので男女間も
その恋愛モノ
的なものに行こう
ハバネロの誕生日感が薄れてしまっているのでこちらがして非常に悔しい面白いです
バレンタインで許されるぞ
笑タイプれ ik 選手の頭メンズバレンタイン許されるぞ
前もってこい
こちらにチョコレート100まで用意しましたガーナチョコレートです誕生日で愛で
たいのはわかるバレンタイン埋めてないと思うんだけど
俺はソイ雑念を今日はねぶち壊せに来たからね誕生日だから取れはそんなニャニャ自分
を何
おめでとうはじめみたいなことしませんよ俺はあのーあれです自分に甘く人に厳しく
違う自分に厳しく人に優しくな
でお馴染できるしていますなんで今日はこちらの板津500マヨ
川奈はれよ汐留100万一気もうそういう音なんかにチョコレートをあげてラブラブ
みたいなそういう立つ名はもういらないんですようちはあれだ
行ってみたいだけど4で下矢田う
板チョコ100万円瓦場にしようと思います
zoome
ブーフ
[音楽]
鮭梅ついたさせました
美味しいん
ん
う
voodoo
ん
うすっバレンタインのちょっと待ってる男う好きな男に告白したい女子モテない男
ういっ
落ちろはちゃんと空からちょっとね食べるんで行くの
voodoo
さあ
[音楽]
re
臭い
[音楽]
ビターねえ飯
オフからの
[音楽]
ブーブー hon フェイサーし
安納 os を入れ野菜ですあのオフ白好きなと思い出しローおっしゃりします本当に